destroyer season occult Kidman deliver
was arguably her best performance in
years the film itself has a lot to
unpack from it and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the movie and its
incredible ending there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about destroyer then I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to destroy it takes place over
several time periods with the movies
opening circling around to conclude the
majority of its story in that initial
scene we follow detective Aaron Bell
played by Kidman who arrives at a crime
scene at this crime scene lies a gunshot
victim with three tattooed dots on the
back of his neck there lies a bunch of
purple dye stain dollar bills around the
victim and Bell informs the officers at
the scene that she knows who did it she
returns to her car completely exhausted
to sit down and rest at the police
station she discovers that someone has
sent her a dye stain bill as a message
and this leads her down a fateful path
in a flashback we see a much younger
looking Aaron meeting undercover agent
Chris played by Sebastian Stan the two
have been tasked with investigating a
gang that commits bank robberies and are
pretending to be a couple in the present
we see that some of the gang have been
incarcerated while others are on the run
Aaron is attempting to track down the
gangs sociopathic leader named Silas and
in a further flashback we see him for
some members to do crazy things like
play Russian roulette for his
entertainment the film bounces back and
forth between time periods and focuses
on Aaron tried to track down the gang
members and leaders whilst rekindling
the relationship that she has with her
daughter named Shelby who is a bit out
of control eventually her trail leads
her to a member named Arturo who
exchanges information with her after
Aaron catches him this leads her to
Silas's attorney who mocks her and
blames her for Chris's death during a
botched robbery attempt the attorney
calls for security who brutally beat her
midsection before she is able to get the
up
eventually she does and gets the
information out of the attorney by
pistol-whipping him until he's a bloody
mess he informs her of a drop that Silas
his girlfriend will be doing and she
travels to this Aaron arrives to this
and similar to herself sees that time
has not been kind to Silas his
girlfriend who was now a drug addict
after following her she learns that they
are just about to commit another bank
robbery and radios for help before
busting out a gun and stopping the
robbery when Silas his girlfriend makes
a run for it Aaron chases her and once
again gets hit in the midsection several
times in the same place that the
security guard damaged her before she
overpowers Silas his girlfriend and
takes her phone leaving her for police
to find and also giving her a way to
contact Silas Shelby has ended up in
hospital after a bar fight with Jay so
Aaron tells her ex-boyfriend Ethan to
take the girl and move to another town
and star a new life she promises him
lots of money and in a flashback we
discovered that Shelby is actually
Chris's child that the two conceived
when they were undercover Aaron and
Chris plan to go ahead with the robbery
and to keep some of the money themselves
and will lie about what happened this
comes to fruition in the present when
Harun arrives at a storage unit where
she hid the money at after the initial
robbery upon opening it though she
discovers that has been covered in
purple dye she takes out the little
amount that is usable and goes to Jay
offering it to him on the proviso that
he never contacts her daughter again
which he accepts after this we finally
see the bank robbery fully play out the
crew get the money and everything seems
like it's going to plan until a dye pack
explodes and the money when they are
leaving
Silas returns to the bank to murder the
staff and so Chris intervenes
identifying himself as an undercover
agent
Silas kills him and the bank teller and
when Aaron sees that Chris doesn't leave
with him she is devastated she drives
away and has to crash the car in order
to escape after suspicion arises as to
whether she is a cop too in the present
Aaron has dinner with Shelby and Aaron
apologizes for everything blaming
herself that her father died the two
share a moment before Silas his
girlfriend's phone goes off with the
text from Silas when she meets him at
the drop point
Silas is amused and asks if she got the
dyed dollar that he sent Aaron shoot and
Silas and spreads the dye stain belt
around him which of course reveals that
he was the corpse at the beginning of
the film now we have the context that
Aaron did it which makes her reveal that
she knows who it was much more poignant
she leaves a note that will allow the
police to trace what has happened before
lifting up her shirt to reveal intense
bruising all over and she is clearly
suffering from internal bleeding
Aaron returns to her car in the same
scene from the opener and looks
completely exhausted we then get a
flashback to when Aaron and Chris
decided to take the money for themselves
it becomes clear that Chris didn't
really want to do it but Aaron begged
him until he agreed to which of course
concludes that she did indeed cause
Chris's death and has been on this
vendetta for justice to you to guilt in
the present Aaron dies from her wounds
with her last memory being that of her
and her daughter's happiest moment
together so what were your thoughts on
destroyer did you enjoy it and is there
anything I missed
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of 2019 s
first horror movie escape room which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]